et maintenant
je mets
voici le petit lens va subir balle mal
bonsoir en pierre les soirs comment ça
va très très bien on est bien dans ce
carré viiip là bas quand j'étais tout
seul c'était pas mal mais c'est que la
belgique est arrivé oui je sais j'ai
préféré venir plateau comme frédéric
vous avez passé vos vacances à g11 un
petit village dans le bar
alwan sainte maxime c'est ça alors dites
moi vous n'avez pas complètement perdu
votre temps à saint tropez ou suivez les
films fait pour les soldats du feu n'ont
oui c'est le régime qui s'est dit parce
que là on était en plein dans le var ont
mis les incendies ont fait rien pour les
pompiers finalement à part les plaindre
et le 18 août et on va essayer de faire
en sorte que tous les ans
le 18 août ça soit un bal pour les
pompiers ça va s'appeler le 18 c'est les
pompiers et communautés parce que oui
alors effet nous ça aurait été pour les
renseignements ont fait le dit gilles
gens que j'ai pour les banquiers par un
des pompiers régine la marraine
comment ça va se passer non non on a
juste lancé cette idée puis voilà on
beaucoup de mères en france sont
d'accord pour que leur village et leur
ville du belize et 1c les pompiers non
tu as tout caritative besoin d'une bonne
idée je dis n'est pas parce que c'est
pas votre idée maintenant vous attendu
s'est voulu semer le fasse sans
frontières vient enfin c'est vrai que
c'est une bonne idée
la soirée des pompiers a été gâchée
quand même par une altercation de régime
non avec dj luigi oui parce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont confondu une soirée
tropézienne avec une soirée à saint
tropez
c'est quoi la différence la différence
c'est que c'est une soirée populaire et
c'était pas une soirée pour pour faire
monter
trois pubs sur la table trois russes et
faire dégommer des bouteilles de
champagne c'était vraiment un bal
populaire pour l'allier et régine donc à
vous lui file un coup de boule à odile
j1 et je les ai empêché j'étais entre
les deux et j'ai fait croire que c'était
bouille de résultats si fait croire que
c'était un sketch et enfin bon en tout
cas c'est anecdotique parce qu'il se bat
là rapporter beaucoup d'argent pour pour
les équipements et voilà quoi ça ne peut
être qu'un bon souvenir hier belle balle
et une conscience sociale maintenant est
ce que est ce que vous êtes d'une
nouvelle votre partenaire en ichel
laroque michel oui on se bat on va
régulièrement elle est revenue de leçons
duré sept ans si elle fait des allées
bien supporté l'été quel bonheur ce
spectacle avec michèle laroque non
écrite et
écoute les gens m'ont parlé c'est vrai
qu'on fait un couple très crédible on
n'a pas d'idées pour continuer pour
l'instant à un troisième etc ou pour
l'instant le nom et puis on veut pas non
plus en faire une recette quoi donc
écouter pierre on a tellement aimé ce
spectacle qu'on a décidé que vous serez
le premier entré dans le panthéon de
tout le monde en parle
non ouais gaillot
moi
pour l'intronisation de clerval
marie-pierre toi et ton cortège de bons
jeux de mots nombre de sketches
magnifique voilà il mérite mais pourquoi
n'y a pas de kouchner déçu berlin ne pas
être entré au panthéon à petit les
regarde la tranche ferme hervé mesnager
non mais le docteur kouchner il s'en
fiche il a le prix nobel de la paix oui
enfin si quand même oui en même temps le
prix nobel de la paix oui d'accord mon
frère d'alain roche pas moi je préfère
avoir mes photos ici
quelle impression cela plus d'être le
premier à entrer au hall of fame de tout
le monde en parle mais bon on sent aimé
par ardisson et ses pas et y en a pas
beaucoup qui peut viser de dire ça est
ce que le public a dû à des questions à
poser à pierre palmade et j'enregistrais
au panthéon ils s'en foutent
complètement
est ce que vous savez qui suis-je
je vais pas de questions à poser à
pierre palmade ici non plus tirer rien
prévient à frédéric beigbeder à une
question fait laïque
ici non plus
si c'est pour le numéro de portable il
l'a déjà donné un délai donné
est-ce que tu m'aies michel à tes côtés
au panthéon
mettez la place tous les deux
oui c'est vrai et c'est pas connu de
tous et spontanément démissionner à
rhodes devrait normalement effet aux
phocéens de tout le monde en parle qui
fait foi la rentrée à part entré au
panthéon tout le monde en parle et vous
déguiser en claude françois j'écris un
album pour rose laurens à telle mémoire
qui m'a demandé d'écrire un album de
chansons pour elle et voilà et puis
écrire des chansons il ya dans les
sketches on peut pas tout on peut pas
dire des choses belles on est obligé
vers des choses drôles et les chansons
wallace intermédiaire dangereux menti ou
ce que vous avez en vous voilà une
chanson
or là avec le taux de ce lot et puis
j'ai fini ma de répondre à thierry je
reviendrai et puis je vais tourner
marie-anne chazel comme acteur fait plus
peur maintenant rêver enfin chez
l'acteur et puis je vais écrire et
muriel robin son nouveau spectacle